the russian missile slammed into the
ground only meters away from this block
of flats
who knows how many people would have
been killed if it had been a direct hit
another attack as part of vladimir
putin's so-called special operation in
ukraine
wrecking civilian lives
even front doors deep inside the
building buckled under the force of the
blast
ludmilla has lived here in the eastern
town of
for more than 50 years
i live here alone
my husband was killed mining coal and my
son died i had gone out for a walk when
it hit
i know how lucky i am to be alive but i
have virtually nothing left how can i
live on i don't know
an old family portrait lies among the
rubble
the books her deceased husband used to
read stand in the destroyed bookcase
family members have come to help
ludmilla clear the debris
olga holds a chunk of shrapnel she found
on the sitting room floor
why did they hit here this is a
residential apartment block why for what
are there tanks here are there soldiers
this is not a battlefield we have a
school here at kindergarten
civil defence teams attach polythene
sheets to one of luke miller's destroyed
windows
other residents throw the remnants of
their belongings onto the pavement below
only seven people suffered minor
injuries in the explosion
it's incredible that nobody was killed
in this attack and it comes at a time
when
according to the ukrainian army russian
forces are preparing for a major
offensive
and they are increasingly attacking
areas like this one
well behind the front line close by a
vast crater scars the woodland where
another missile exploded
the ukrainian military says russian
forces are gradually increasing the
intensity of their offensive in eastern
ukraine
tattered wallpaper hangs in shards from
lumila's kitchen wall
she says she hopes the ukrainian army
can keep russian forces back
and she doesn't know what she will do
if they come
ciao stratford al jazeera
pillia eastern ukraine